heroes duty
we all love to watch disney animated
movies even though we are no longer kids
and that's partly because there are some
pretty hilarious puns that we never
properly understood when we were young
and innocent
do you remember watching disney movies
as a kid and certain moments passing by
that you didn't understand
like us you probably never thought twice
about them but now re-watching those old
nostalgia classics you totally get those
puns hidden in the films
it's so satisfying to be in on the in
jokes it's almost as if disney movies
were made for adults but asking king
crap
caesar salad anna reveals some personal
details about her preferences at the end
of frozen two when kristoff gets all
dressed
up for her coronation in a suit he tells
her one hour
you get this for one hour but anna
doesn't mind because she likes her bae
dressed up in quite a different way
it's a wink-wink nudge-nudge moment for
us adults that's okay i prefer you and
leather anyway
when cogsworth is giving belle a guided
tour of the castle he shows her examples
of the late neoclassic baroque period
and that gives the talking clock the
opportunity to have a little wordplay
fun
he certainly finds it funny laughing
away to himself does it bring a wry
smile to your lips now
as i always say if it's not baroque
don't fix it
we love mushu for his comedy value the
little dragon certainly knows how to
lighten heavy moments like when mulan
has a heart to heart with him about her
self-doubt
he's sweet and serious for a moment but
then in true mushu fashion he drops some
word play
and has fun with the name of their enemy
the
[Music]
well huns go kick some honey bun
you've gotta love how vanellope lets her
childlike side shine through
like finding it hilarious when someone
says a word that unintentionally sounds
rude this happens with ralph when he
talks about winning a medal in the game
heroes duty vanellope can't help but
crack up about his pronunciation of the
word and she goes off on a long riff
about poop
heroes duty
it's not that kind of duty sassy zazu is
responsible for
plenty of puns in the lion king as he
reels them off super fast it's pretty
likely that they go right over kids
heads
just like little simba doesn't notice as
his dad's busy trying to teach him but
as adult viewers we certainly appreciate
the birds many
animal puns the buzz from the bees is
that the leopards are in a bit of a spot
on the subject of animal puns mr potato
head comes out with a cracker in toy
story when he sticks his facial features
on in a lopsided way he jokes picasso
but the pig doesn't get his reference to
the distorted faces that the artist
created so mr potato head plays around
with
another word for pig you want cultured
swine
it's not just toy story that had some
fun with a picasso pun when lilo shows
stitch her room
in blue tinged twilight he starts
ripping her artwork apart
she screams at him to stop explaining
that it's from a particular chapter in
her artistic development
and not many young kids will know all
about picasso's monochromatic phase
no that's from my blue
jafar is surprisingly fond of a pun for
a villain and he brings out a memorable
one-liner when he thinks he's finally
about to defeat jasmine and aladdin
as he throws her into the sand timer he
throws out a phrase that's normally used
metaphorically
but in this scenario it's also literal
our princess your time is up chief bogo
isn't exactly known for his humor and
that's why it's so funny when his
straight face delivery turns into a
classic pun
during judy's first meeting at the
zootopia police department
we didn't see that one coming and little
ones wouldn't have understood the
subtlety
even after the fact we need to
acknowledge the elephant in the room
francine happy birthday when nemo and
his fellow aquatic friends are swimming
around in their filthy tank at the
dentist surgery it all becomes too much
for gurgle
as he watches bloat the porcupine fish
eat up some green gunk he calls out the
disgusting behavior
his rude word is interrupted just in
time by peach the starfish but us
grown-ups all know what he was going to
say
don't you people realize we are swimming
in our own
here we come inside out has some
friendly fun with the residents of san
francisco with this locals joke
fear worries that there's a bear to
which disgust replies
there are no bears in san francisco and
anger comes along with the punchline
as adults we all get the reference to
the bear figure in the lgbtq plus
community
i saw a really hairy guy he looked like
a bear mater is a great source of humor
in cars but surely his funniest moment
is when he mishears lightning mcqueen
talking about doc he won three piston
cups because piston certainly sounds
like something else if you can't quite
hear
we definitely hope that young children
didn't get that pun
given that moana was released in 2016
it's no surprise that the writers took
the opportunity to include puns about
social media when maui uses the rooster
heihei to autograph moana's paddle he
cracks a joke about twitter that one
would definitely go over the heads of
little kids who aren't online yet
when you use a bird to write with it's
called tweeting
we've already covered jafar's puns but
of course the genie is the one who's
behind
most of the humor in aladdin and he
dishes out plenty of puns that only
adults get
it's hard to choose just one but this
little nugget is a favorite
it's all about the sheep humor robin
williams we salute you
oh i feel sheepish all right you bad boy
when anna follows elsa to the ice palace
she drops a hilarious line while singing
the reprise of for the first time in
forever
talking about the trouble back home anna
sings i get the feeling you don't know
to which elsa replies
what do i not know
[Music]
deep deep deep snow
as adults we all expect a different word
than snow to end the familiar idiom
hilarious when the abominable snowman
welcomes mike and sully to the himalayas
he offers them a sweet treat but when he
sees mike's disgusted reaction to his
yellow snow cones he cracks a funny
response
we sure hope the kiddos won't know why
else snow cones might be yellow
snow cone no no no don't worry
it's lemon some of these puns go over
the heads of kids because they involve a
kind of knowledge you only get when
you're older
like roman numerals like when hercules
gets called to the rescue and the child
calls out a number that plays on an
ancient emergency number
even us adults have to take a beat to
work out what the numerals stand for
can't get enough of zazu's wordplay then
listen up for this one
it's another animal joke where the
hornbill plays around with the dual
meanings of words that sound the same
cheetahs never prosper this one's the
sort of joke that's a bit too subtle for
the smallest ones to get but as an adult
it raises a wry smile because it's
actually so
amusingly childish we're talking about
the moment the guard takes flynn to jail
and bangs on the door of the cell the
password conversation that follows with
the white bearded character called
shorty
is good fun what's the password what
no open this door not even
close when rey first meets tiana and
naveen he says they must be new to those
parts
naveen explains in his best fairy tale
way
far far away from this world but the
firefly doesn't get it and replies with
a line that will go right over kid's
heads
syndrome comes up with an adults-only
response when he's asked what the s
stands for on his supervillain costume
sitter yeah sitter
originally i was gonna have initials for
babysitter yes
we understand why he didn't go ahead
with that let's assume that kids
won't but then i would have been going
around wearing a big bs and you
understand why i couldn't go with that
the moment barbie and ken meet in toy
story 3 is brilliant
not least because of the pun that barbie
comes out with after ken compliments her
on her leg warmers she compliments him
on his choice of neckwear but the way
she pronounces his tie draws attention
to another part of his anatomy
rather than his neck love your leg
warmers
nice ass cut judy hopps plays on
rabbit's reputation for having a lot of
babies with a fun bit of wordplay when
she talks about being a bunny that's
good at math
or the other meaning of that word you'll
get what she means but little kids
definitely won't think i mean i am just
a dumb bunny but
we are good at multiplying anyway
lumiere and the feather duster have
quite the love story in beauty and the
beast and when the candelabra tries to
romance his bae
she comes out with a pun that plays on
his flames as well as his previous bad
behavior
we're pretty sure this one's a bit too
sophisticated for kids to understand
i've been banned by you before frozen
has so many
funny punny moments that we just had to
include one more
the sleigh ride scene kristoff is asking
anna how well she knows hans quizzing
her on his surname favorite food
best friend's name and eye color but
it's his final question that has
us cracking up or should we say anna's
answer
yep that's a reference only adults will
get switches
best friend's name probably john eye
color dreamy what size foot size doesn't
matter
that's confirmed it disney animated
movies are even better when you watch
them as an adult
which is your favorite pun be sure to
let us know in the comments section
and please hit that like button to show
your love for all things disney thanks
for watching
[Music]
you